hey there i'm philip molina still
dressed in my bingeing blues because I
am binge watching Jessica Jones season
one and along the way I'm going to give
you my thoughts and analysis on the
episodes plus I'm going to point out I
don't know a bunch of like little
details that I think might easily be
missed but let's go ahead and do it this
is a breakdown of Jessica Jones season 1
episode 2 crush syndrome let's explore
the concept of what it means to actually
be in control up first we always take a
look at our opening images where here we
see Jessica using a mirror to take in
the room around her so she's continuing
that thing of examining the truth of her
surroundings by putting a layer of glass
between her and them but know she
doesn't want to look at herself in that
mirror she doesn't want to see the truth
about herself
it's interesting to remember that in the
previous episode we met justiça through
the window of a door and in this one is
through the glass of a mirror because
mirrors always flip reality and as we
can see she's in a police station being
interrogated regarding that murder of
hopes parents but Jessica's much closer
to being a victim in that situation and
yet they're kind of treating her like
the flipped version of that an
accomplice or a killer like as the
detective gets more pointed with his
questions asking her if she knew that
hope was gonna kill her parents you can
see that he also knows the benefit of
looking not directly at someone to see
if they're lying but instead into the
glass to make the call about the truth
and throughout this scene they're both
fighting to be the one in control of the
narrative and correctly painting what
actually happened to Hope and her
parents and did you notice the
revelation in this scene that Jessica's
been taking even more pictures of Luke
than we thought
like either she's a clingy stalker type
or more likely she's got like a real
reason to be going all p.i on him then
we move on through glass windows and
doors and Jessica seems to come clean
about following Luke but like she
already knows and we find out a little
later she's not coming fully clean at
all which transitions nicely to her
feeling like she needs a shower and then
she takes his real look at herself in
the mirror where she really judges
herself probably not feeling clean at
all and even if she wanted to be clean
that is not in her power because when
there is a roach just a couple of inches
away from an image of herself then it's
impossible for her to feel
anything but gross if you listen to the
narration too you can easily connect
that that roach is a representation of
kilgrave yeah she wants to feel rid of
her disgusting past and her disgusting
actions but there he is just outside of
her view ready to make everything feel
old freakin gross again Jessica does try
to assert some dominance over the roach
as she wonders how killgrave escaped the
death she thought she saw him suffer
but just like kilgrave the roach also
cheats death and we shift over to
Jessica trying to squeeze any
information at all out of hope that can
help her catch kilgrave and Jessica kind
of gets a taste of her own medicine from
that earlier interrogation scene because
now despite whatever she's trying to
make this interview about hope his other
plans hope just wants to talk about
kilgrave's obsession with Jessica then
hope lashes out at Jessica for not
making sure that kilgrave died in that
accident because that was they both know
the one moment where someone could have
had control over him and then hope
suggests you should kill yourself and
yeah that's awkward she sounds like
she's leaving a mean youtube comment but
I think what she's actually doing there
is suggesting the only choice that she
thinks is actually within Jessica's
control oh also dude in the background I
know you're trying to help but yet she's
not gonna want that thing when you're
holding it with a purple glove do some
research man she doesn't like purple and
now just may not be able to get what she
wants out of this kilgrave and Hope
situation but she does do everything
that is in her power to twist Jerry into
taking on hopes case even though Jerry
thinks it's a loser case which when she
says that I bet you guys just like me
were like oh I know another Hell's
Kitchen lawyer that might take on a
loser case can we see him please
but maybe later then on her way home our
perspective shifts to watching Jessica
and it ends up being just Trish but this
is definitely a foreshadowing this idea
that somebody else might be out there
spying or watching Jessica which is fun
because that's what she does for a
living
more taste of her own medicine then we
see Jessica still hasn't fixed that door
and there's no way to even lock it they
say so she is still susceptible to being
invaded and just also reminds Trish that
nobody can be trusted anyone could be
under kilgrave's mind-control and I love
this detail because it means that from
here on out in this show any damn
see anybody on screen even like an extra
in the background Jessica and us have to
both wonder Oh are they about to kill
her and like the face slick and he weird
smile the last episode I'm gonna
nominate this realization here is one of
the most unsettling moments of this
episode Jessica then studies the
newspaper clipping about the accident
that supposedly killed kilgrave and
there are two names that pop out on this
article
Reba Conners who apparently was killed
in the same accident but Jay King is
short for Jaime King who is the writer
on this show then Jessica followed some
clues right to Metro general the same
hospital Daredevils Claire temple works
at and I was really hoping that Claire
would show up at some point though in
the meantime we do get a few other
Easter eggs on the chart you can see dr.
Bendis as in Brian Michael Bendis the
creator of Jessica Jones there's nurse
Panucci Oh a moment later which is a
reference to the show's prop master and
then there's this really interesting one
actually it's actually right when they
walk in two cops are desperate to find
some records on Wilson and then
Daredevils main villain Wilson Fisk
connected world is connected so just
find out who was driving the bus but the
audience that gets to see a picture of
Reba Connors and if you remember last
episode that's the same woman from the
picture in Luke's medicine cabinet so
now you know a little bit more about
Luke Cage this scene also places the
Jessica Jones timeline for us because
the bus accident was about a year ago
and Reva Connors was admitted in January
2014
so that means right now in this show
it's around January 2015 which would put
it a few months before the events of
Avengers age of Ultron then headed back
home Jessica gets a pretty chilling
reminder of how dangerous this situation
is when she notices that not all the
blood from that elevator murder has been
cleaned and so it's no surprise that
yeah she's a bit on edge when she
accidentally destroys that poor door
repair guy's legs so he was sent by
Trish to fix her door and that's yeah
nice gesture but Trish doesn't realize
that taking choices out of Jessica's
hands right now is not a good way to
mend their friendship you gotta let
Jessica control something right now she
needs it then Jessica follows a lead
that could lead her to how killgrave
escaped his
suppose a death and the PTSD flashbacks
are kind of starting to get more
frequent especially when you're
surrounded by a bunch of people who
could be under kilgrave's control and
maybe one of them's gonna kill you
so yeah it's no surprise that this
moment is accompanied by glass
shattering as Jessica starts to lose a
little bit of her grip on what's real
and what's true and when Jessica finds
the guy who drove kilgrave's ambulance
and she learns that oh my god he stole
boats the guy's kidneys and then you
combine that with the moment where you
think the guys riding killgrave but he's
riding kill me yeah this is another
nominee for most unsettling moment of
this episode it also connects back to
that suggestion hope gave Jessica
earlier this guy's on that same page
kilgrave has already taken everything
else away from him the one thing he can
choose is whether or not he lives or
dies but sadly he actually doesn't even
have that amount of control cuz
Jessica's not gonna do it for him later
the accidental home wrecker Luke Cage
gets attacked by the husband of the lady
he's been sleeping with and oh man was
this fight amazing it's worth watching
just for Luke's face the entire time
because when you can't be damaged you
have no need to block a punch like the
whole thing is just mildly annoying to
you the best moments include his eye
roll and the laziest bitch-slap I've
ever seen Frank now compare that
fighting style to Jessica's and it's
pretty clear which of them has issues
with control
Jessica then tracks kilgrave's
life-saving surgeon to a college and
while he doesn't trust her at first he
doesn't actually explain how he saved
him
and he also named dropped the episodes
title when he explains that the accident
lets kilgrave's suffering from crushing
syndrome which apparently refers to a
situation where when your skeletal
muscle is too badly damaged your kidneys
shut down Jessica also realizes that
because kilgrave wouldn't allow himself
to go under during the surgery then he
must be afraid of the chemicals that can
interrupt his ability to control minds
and suddenly she has something she's
never had before kilgrave's weakness now
because it's so prevalent like all the
time I'm not going to point it out every
time but the entire scene here you can
definitely see that there's multiple
purple lights in the background and in
the distance I think as kilgrave
- Jessica we're gonna see more and more
that throughout the season until
eventually we're just like totally
bathed and purple later Jessica gets a
gift to help her complete the door and
it reminds her that she might not want
Trish to get involved in fixing
Jessica's situation it still can't be
denied that when Trish does help things
do get done that means she might need
her friends to help her regain the
control that she's lost so only when she
realizes this does she set up this lunch
date with Trish and as the episode wraps
up we finally meet kilgrave although we
still don't get any direct looks at him
but he mind controls this man and forces
him into inviting him into his home then
he makes the kids lock themselves away
and then states that he's got a very
particular palate and wields an freakin
knife and yes I am thoroughly creeped
out by all this but I'm actually more
intrigued by the parallels of this
moment to one of film history's oldest
monsters Dracula keep in mind that
vampires also don't enter a home until
they're invited in and they also have a
very particular palette and that knife
is kind of confirming yeah that palette
it's a thirst for blood and finally in
some stories about Dracula he gets a few
extra powers over the average vampire
including mind control you remember
Buffy come on puppy shirt tuck around up
cuz you can kiss your pale ass
yes master and I gotta say kilgrave
definitely feels like he's building up
to being one of the most iconic monsters
of all time
I mean why got a step on the little kids
car like I thought you liked purple man
now into our closing images like our
opening we see Jessica's reflection but
things are a little different this time
jessica has once again tried to get
herself clean but when our little
kilgrave Roach guy returns from his
grave her narration reminds us that now
that she has the knowledge of kilgrave's
weakness the power dynamic like the
mirror image of jessica is flipped and
now she's got the control she goes from
having been under kilgrave's thumb to
putting kilgrave the little Roach guy
under her thumb giving him his second
taste of crushing syndrome and the
closing images of the episodes others
storyline have Luke coming clean about
his powers and you get this line that
she doesn't need to fix him because he's
already unbreakable as you can see by a
crazy power saw to the ABS moment now
this reveal here is a nice callback to
the kind of
make intimacy that they tried to have
last episode cuz if you think about it
then when Jessica was the one claiming
that she couldn't be broken they're
definitely trying to have a connection
but here in touching where his wound
should be she's actually connecting to
him much more in a real way also did
anybody else kind of think we were gonna
get a Netflix like cross-promotion
moment when Luke says this line you
can't fix me now some lingering thoughts
I think it's really interesting that
Jessica's door which still represents
access to her mind and her safety I has
a temporary block on it but it very
clearly is marked fragile like it's
nowhere near sturdy also lots of talk
about Trish's mom being a psycho and
clearly she's part of the reason why
Trish is making herself get krav maga be
and while Patty's mom was always pretty
crazy in the comics this all makes you
wonder like okay but how crazy are you
guys gonna make her oh also with Trish
we know that she eventually becomes
Hellcat who's kind of a badass hero in
her own right but it's really fun that
we're getting to see her origin story
here to on finally I gotta admit the
moments with the kids was bad I kill me
was bad and there were a lot of nominees
for most unsettling moments in this
episode but for me it was definitely the
freaking of the roach crush ah with your
bare hand what do you uh what he can do
I'm gonna cut off your thumb now oh
alright how are you doing are you also
binging this hang in there if you are
also let me know what you think so far
about the show on Twitter you can hit me
up at fimo and also in the comments down
below feel free to discuss everything
let's just remember to try to keep our
discussion to episodes 1 & 2 we don't
want anybody who's also benching to get
spoiled as they binge as for me I am so
ready to go right into episode 3 it's
called it's called whiskey you can click
over there if it's up yet to watch that
analysis if you haven't checked out my
now since 4 episode 1 yet go back and
watch that it explains why this show is
so freaking obsessed with doors and
windows and glass I've been phill'd
Molina let's do it onto the next one
you